[Musique]
vendredi deux joints à la mairie de
petite île s'est tenu une réception en
l'honneur de l'équipe unss tel robic du
collège joseph suacot les neuf membres
de cette équipe
organe de métropole du championnat de
france unss aérobic à des glo titre de
vice championne
c'est la concrétisation d'un long
travail une grande fierté déjà prononcés
on a représenté la réunion comme ça fait
déjà deux ans qu'on se présente ça fait
combien de temps qu'on l'attend et
madame ben ça fait déjà à 54 7 médailles
qu'on ait servi à avoir apporté ses
titres s'égorger bien que c'est une très
belle aventure parce que finalement j'ai
vu des choses merveilleuses hyper fier
trop contente on l'attendait ce type
depuis longtemps ça fait cinq ans que le
collège petit il va au championnat de
france et c'est la première fois qu'on
arrive à à décrocher une médaille
d'occurences du très fier d'elle
elles ont vécu de belles choses c'était
une belle aventure sportive certes mais
surtout humaine et voilà des souvenirs
pour toujours pendant les discours
l'émotion se lit sur les visages et
devant des parents ravis
la cérémonie est l'occasion de féliciter
les collégiennes c'est une façon pour
nous de mettre en valeur nos talents et
montrer tout l'attachement que nous
avons à encourager notre jeunesse qui
peut réussir avec beaucoup de volonté de
détermination et de conviction
c'est le résultat que nous ramenions de
ces championnats de france fière de ma
fière de l'équipe
beaucoup d'efforts 3 arriver à ce
résultat c'est un bon esprit des clips
et en plus de ça c'est une découverte et
une très bonne expérience
le département qui aide les associations
sportives au sein des collèges est fier
d'accompagner cette jeunesse qui réussit
et s'épanouit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]